reject nation book of boba fett chapter
five it's a thick one it's a long one
what are we hoping for baby yoda yo grug
we're hoping a little den jordan's gonna
show back up today
two grown creepy ass men talking
guys if you can go ahead use the force
to hit that like button that would be
very much appreciated also subscribe to
get notified when our next reaction for
boba fett is up as always full length
watch along where you sync up with the
time code for book above a feder over at
our patreon page massive thank you to
all who have become superjects today
showing your support for the channel and
checking all the content we gotta offer
there and as always thanks to the boys
of prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights and we must continue
our segment of things that we got wrong
or completely flew over our heads last
week and the only one that we really got
wrong was uh we couldn't quite remember
the whole thing with wookie and trend
oceans their history like i've seen
clone wars and i i didn't remember the
episodes that explored this according to
some of the comments from last week but
yeah apparently there's a whole history
of enslaving them that they didn't even
establish in the one of the earlier
episodes of this show where they brought
in the pelton yeah yeah
like a child wookie it looked like so
get ready correct us on whatever we get
wrong in this episode we'll bring it up
next episode thank you guys because
that's what comment boxes are for i'm
watching a whole like 40 minute video
and only commenting what we get wrong
you're helping out the channel
this on the same planet we're in the
mandalorian episode with uh
i think that's him
let's do this i'm here for kabab
i'm here to bring him in
well
if i see him
i'll let him know
i see him right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's not me
that doesn't even look like me
you're racist
let's discuss our options
i can bring you in warm
or i can bring you in cold i can bring
you in like a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and in two pieces
that's right i have the dark side back
he's like the ahsoka this season yeah
[Laughter]
you all can help yourselves to whatever
you think you deserve
from your former employer
just give us mandalorian season three
you know what we want
[Music]
it's the body like ah yes
do it
[Music]
that's a ship he upgraded
to elysium yes
i'd put that on ice if i were you
well with the background this is one of
the most beautiful one takes i've seen
in a while great use of sound design too
the hilt is of a quality of best car i
have never seen before
it was forged over a thousand years ago
by the mandalore tar whistler
i have met jedi and you have completed
your quest
then you may join our covert as we
rebuild this is the way
this is the way this is the way this is
the
damn way
[ __ ] a
andalorian steel is meant for armor not
weapons then forge it into armor
wow an honorable man
had our sect not been cloistered on the
moon of concordia
we would have not survived the great
purge
we're gonna actually see inside yeah
yeah i bet we
those are of mandalore strayed away from
the path
eventually the imperial interlopers
destroyed all that we knew and loved in
the night of a thousand tears oh golly
[Music]
it's like a nuclear air raid
[Applause]
how heroin
[Music]
recap all the necessary information you
would have needed to watch the clone
wars and star wars troubles
just
[Music]
[Music]
that is because you are fighting against
the blade you should be fighting against
your opponent the blade should be an
extension of you i am focused
the blade says otherwise
[Music]
maybe the dark saber belongs in someone
else oh [ __ ]
oh
don't get knocked off i have loved it
come on buddy
whoa
[Music]
come on
have you ever removed your helmet
i think once or twice no comment
i have
then you are a mandalorian no more
what
i beg you for your forgiveness oh
according to creed one may only be
redeemed in the living waters beneath
the mines of mandalore
but the mines have all been destroyed
this is the way there's only like three
of you
come on guys can i take the dark saber
with me
they set us up for mandalorians
claim that status
also win back mandalore build a home for
new waters to re-emerge from
[Music]
[Music]
it's not the same green creature
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is it a womp
it is a warm bread okay it's not here
maybe it ran
oh jesus
jurassic park it's a very strong one
[Music]
what an entrance
you're good
good holy crap i knew i recognized that
droid it's bd1 from jedi fallen order oh
man uh yeah yeah i should have called
that out of the moment i should have
still haven't got that clear live-action
look
never ever will
where's your unlikely companion
i returned him to his own kind where the
hell would you do that
where's the ship
it's right this way
[Music]
now this is padre
and i know she doesn't look like much
but you got here a lot earlier than i
expected and and i didn't get a chance
to finish i mean clearly you can see
i've got all the parts right here
it's a good ship and in a few years
it'll fly where did you get this it's
brand new well
jawa new they give me what i asked for
in exchange i let them pick through my
dumpster can i meet them yeah sure r5
see if the javas are still out back
r5 lives on break free oh they're
waiting for that don't worry about the
shape and size just get the parts you
want the specs you need and i'm gonna
make it work all right i dated a chawa
oh
that's okay i'm working on me right now
just go find the party
i just want one piece of concept art
with her in a java i thought i'd be so
excited for a prequel ship where does
this panel go
thanks little guy
oh buddy you want to thank me now or you
want to thank me later you get me a
razor crest you can have it right back
oh bantha diddle these are a lot harder
to come by than some plain old razor
crest razor crest
i feel like he utilizes the razor cross
shape the size of it i feel like it had
a use for everything on that ship yeah
he uses the space he's got to be able to
take prisoners
i got it they said they crawled under a
pike spice runner and crimped it off
while they were refueling
pike spices
pikes do not mess around ever since
they've been moving spice to the system
everything's gone to hell everyone's
afraid of them and law enforcement won't
even go near them except one guy
it fits
[Music]
[Laughter]
wake up the suns are up
yes
[Music]
now they sobered it out look at that
stripped all that yellow off
oh
not a gram of fat honor you know no
one's catching you in this thing
they put that thing together [ __ ]
fast
yeah like an afternoon
[Laughter]
start her up
really yeah start her up
[Music]
sure
it's really mine huh it's working
it's working
oh no
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about give me
the top of the town
dang farrick
awesome
[Laughter]
she tracks like a rails feeder
[Music]
that's a thumbnail
finally
[Music]
yeah go wave at that kid
mcclunky
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're also operating without a beacon
i'm gonna need you to run one for us
who's this cameo i think we can let him
off with the warning this time thank you
officer
i'll have that taken care of one thing
before you go
yes
your voice is mighty familiar do you
used to fly a razor crest oh no i think
you have the wrong guy officer
you mind answering a few questions
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
attack of the clones
that respect
must legitimize all past installments
how was it
wizard
an old friend of yours dropped by said
she was looking for you a friend of mine
don't worry i told her i didn't know
where you were then i locked her out and
engaged the hangar security system
she tell you her name then
oh yeah there's a book of boba fett
hey is good
[Music]
what's the bounty no bounty
we need muscle boba fett
he sure would appreciate it tell him
it's on the house
awesome but first
i gotta pay a visit to a little friend
dallas
is
he has no clue he's got a clone worship
[ __ ]
that ship's seen so much battle man yeah
try to remember wasn't there another
like thing in the mandalorian where he
he also had like one of anakin's he had
a piece of attitude pod racing yeah they
wasn't
yeah yeah he had like a
speeder made out of one of the racer
engines yeah yeah yeah it's just a
vandalian episode i know i thought it's
gonna be like the socas episode where
it's like oh we're just kicking it off
with her here and then we'll cut back
and forth
with his side she's just like no we're
just going to do a mandible right
episode pretty much this is a little
teaser for season three
this is funny that was crazy i like how
they took this episode to give us all
the backstory
that did not give the freaking
actual mandalorian show when the dark
stairs introduced when they throw it all
in here
part of me is wondering if this is all
going to be a great big meanwhile
to fill in some holes so that season
three could be boba and mando teamed up
it's like let's explain bo katan bisla
they didn't bring us to being rent at
all which i thought was interesting
but that's true it was just handed off
to her at the end there i really enjoyed
the last few episodes of bugaboo fed a
lot but there is something about like
this is it just feels like there's an
injection of momentum
and then the fact that we're actually
traveling through space at some point
a setting too with that big ring that
like we haven't even really seen before
instead of being in places that we have
seen and that are being fleshed out yeah
yeah i don't recall what that is if it's
been in clone wars rebels guys you can
just uh feel free to you know
tell us in the comments we'll bring it
up next episode but yeah that was great
that was that was awesome so fun
that was awesome
can't wait to see him in boba
yeah man talk it out
be who be mono syllabic together do you
remember me i am
and jaren
i need your help
uh let's shitty chat well that was a
great one the first episode of the
mandalorian season three is here with us
today
those quotes i i think that's the first
time we've seen a womp rat in live
action
glory i'm pretty sure that's the case
right am i wrong about that we've seen
womp rat and other mediums of star wars
but
i can't recall the time that's what i've
been always itching for is like i hope
we see a whomp brand in live action
and we finally hit that's my main
takeaway he's like nothing for fun
a new hope you know so i'm just like
come on man legendary let's see some
damn womp
it only took 40 years to say
um but if i'm wrong about that just just
tell me and i'm just not remembering
that correctly but no this was this was
a great episode this was this was
wonderful so much more
than i i wasn't expecting just a full
blown let's just make it a mando focused
episode getting the return of dinjar and
catching up there with
so much
um you know paz vizsla the armor
and yeah as they like go through the
whole
back story of so much um to unpack there
i love the training sequence between
the armor and mando because uh in in
rebels when sabine wren
has the dark saber she's training with
kanan
and kanan is jedi
so she's like learning from a jedi
directly and so that scene was making me
think of that
but there's a lot of different context
around it because you know as as much as
the armor respects the ways of the force
she herself is not a jedi
and you know they're fighting styles and
their their belief systems there's a lot
of difference and all the differences
there
so you're getting a different type of
training sequence but there's still
motifs about it that make make one
hearken back to those moments and i
believe dave filoni was involved with
ruppel i think that was his show too i
think so
he's like everything animated star wars
has his hand on something anything like
monumental tv assistant yeah
yeah so uh to be to be harkening back to
that of course i thought was just
wonderful to behold
and um
yeah uh with you know past vizila
wanting it it's like if you're a
visceral you're going to want that saver
it's just plain and simple
anything that clone wars taught me is
like if you're damn bizla you're going
to want that damn dark saber and so
having having a fight between them and
yeah it does make sense to me of
it's like they've still been teasing so
much of like what what happened with the
fall of mandalore
um under bo katan's rule because at the
end of rebels
sabine rent hands over the dark saber to
her but she didn't as as armor
establishes they didn't win it by creed
meaning they didn't win it by
finding it out
so i guess there must i like that it
holds that much more credence and weight
towards the fact that
one does have to earn possession of this
especially if you are indeed an actual
mandalorian one has to earn possession
of this
and uh you know if anyone deserves to
rule mandalore i think it's bokeh town
because she just keeps losing it
she's trying to take it
he just keeps trying to unite man
and then every time you catch up with
her i was like oh never mind it's gone
what happens someday because my viewing
experience is different than a lot of
people's with star wars it's like it's a
of the animated it's like i watched
mando season one
then i watched clone wars
and by the time i watched clone wars the
last season was out whereas on most
people
watch clone wars
then it got cancelled
and then they watched rebels
and then they watched mandalorian
or
and or i forget the order and uh but
then the mandel but then clone wars
final season came out
um way later by the when disney plus was
out right so
i i had a different experience
with it whereas like captain rex is in
star wars rebels so when i watch star
wars clone wars i was like oh my god is
captain rex gonna die but then what if i
had my troubles i would have known that
so basically i'm trying to just i don't
know i'm just giving you guys like my
viewing experience but i i forget names
and all that pretty pretty easily just
in general with any show so yeah just to
unpack some of the lore here where
you know we're uncovering everything
with the dark saber and the significance
but also going back to like i like the
consequences of him removing his helmet
you know like that's that because he did
it so much in season two yeah yeah
and that being the sort of deciding
factor of like well you guys are pretty
evenly matched and dinjon's got the
upper hand on you and now it just comes
down to protocols yeah yeah now it comes
down to how good of a mandalorian have
you been well i like the way that scene
was executed too because when he's you
know being questioned about that he's
just quiet
it's like he knows right then and
they're like oh [ __ ] i didn't actually
asked about this
and what to do i can't say anything
i guess i'll just not say anything
but then yeah this felt like this just
felt like more pure star wars again like
i've been enjoying book above with that
i feel like i've enjoyed it more than
much more than most people yeah it's
like you know online i'm just like damn
some people are really backing around
and uh i've really been enjoying it a
lot um but there is sort of this
propellant almost jumping into
hyperspace effect where when mando shows
up or you're like oh god yeah this is
just so much better with him
it feels like there's more natural
momentum you know and i i've really
enjoyed seeing everything we've seen up
until this point with boba fett but i
think especially in the present day like
it's clear that you know this mandalori
this dinjarin experience is happening
pretty close to present day for boba
fett at least as of this show and i feel
like up until this point you know most
the flashbacks with boba fett have been
what's really interesting and so now as
they meet up maybe we will get some real
momentum in the present you know well i
it weirdly
if anything the the weird part about it
is having this episode in particular
especially one that's solely focused to
mando to the point where i didn't even
like care to check in with boba yeah
it
kind of highlights some problems with
boba fett the series so far
where i'm like you know i barely even
barely see mando's face like we've only
seen it a few times and i'm like we
spend a good amount of like boba talks a
lot more than we probably expected he's
even commented on that he saw some more
horses
yeah he talks about you you see his face
a lot you know it's and and um
it's like i'm just so much more endeared
towards him and to
and by the time you get like you you
establish a motive here with with denjar
granted we have two seasons worth of
character with him and like i wasn't
instantly attached to danjarin right
away uh like i was drawn to him but i
wasn't like oh you know i'm not gonna
cry over the guy
um
but
here you know it's like uh crap uh he's
stripped of being qualified as an actual
mandalorian and that's what it's all
about he wants to go see grogu like his
motives
i'm instantly like really connected and
drawn towards and want to see that
journey so much more
than i do care about the actual why of
what boba's doing like it's it's bizarre
because it's somehow i was really
invested in that and now i don't care as
much
because of this episode so this is such
a strong episode and yet it also made me
go well i don't really care about the
cause of being of
that i don't care what's going to bring
them together i don't really yeah i'm
not as invested now in boba's journey
because now i just want to see this
journey well yeah i don't know i mean
there are a million reasons that could
be and i guess here and now i'm sitting
here thinking it's just that personal
edge of like you know him and grogu that
connection has such a gravity
surrounding a lot more
whereas yeah like i i think it's fun
watching boba fett set up his ethical
crime empire but also
i don't know there's something that
doesn't feel quite as personal about
that journey i guess it feels like a
thing an opportunity that's arisen that
boba fett sees the chance to take
whereas this feels like you know there's
you feel how and it's not even a huge
part of the episode but you kind of feel
how lonely he feels without grogu and
even that is just like a little unspoken
layer but even now that he's you know
back doing bounties as usual he's still
thinking about the child he's still
propelled there and two checking in with
the mandalorian history and you know the
stuff about like tar viz was a
combination of a mandalorian and a jedi
and he's you know learning the dark
saber like that even got me just like my
mind going
in a way that some of the boba fett
stuff doesn't get me you know like
poking out into all different avenues of
like where could this go next you know
like it feels a lot more contained and
linear with boba fett whereas dinjarin
and two i mean like boba fett everything
is very
set on we're setting up some here on
tattooing whereas like boba
dinjaran you know mandalorian you're
always traveling to different places and
you're sort of always on the run which
has a different flavor to it i think
just from the get-go well it's like the
boba fett series is it is kind of a
weird paradox with this episode that i
think occurs because the the boba fett
series
um what the things i appreciate about it
is that it does it's like it's primarily
on tattooing it's going for this like
you know star wars gangster survived
um it's it's more has more of this
gritty slower paced tone to it sometimes
a lot more meditative especially when
you're dealing with a flashback arena um
so
i'm that's why i'm really drawn to it
because of because of all those reasons
and i thought with
you know it was reported that ninja
would show up in the show
and so i was under the presumption that
this would really highlight the
differences between mandalorian series
and the book of boba fett series and so
what they instead did was they got bryce
dallas howard who has directed two
two episodes of the mandalorian already
um each from a season
and then she pretty much did what she
pretty much made a mandalorian episode
so it didn't feel like dinjarin in the
book of boba fett world
it just felt like the mandalorian the
whole time yeah yeah you know and
um and so i i i was under the
presumption that this would feel like
okay this would really show us with
denjar being in here in with boba as the
lead and maybe that's what the later
episodes will do yeah maybe that's what
the progression will do where it's like
you're plucking it because because tonal
wise like just the vibe of mandalorian
in the book of boba fett are very
different from each other
so i that so i don't know if this is
actually doing a disservice to boba fett
yeah
and that's what i mean where the paradox
might come in is
is like this is just like so much more
uh there is more of an energy to it and
even even like the personality of uh din
jar in a lot of ways just feels a little
bit more
relatable
something about yeah i don't know what
it is and even just him the actor and i
again i really love tim ware morrison
and i love you know what
i don't i guess i've learned not to
assume that it's always the actor in the
suit even though you're tamara morris
and you see him in the suit a lot more
uh but yeah there's just something about
the dinjar and body like he just has
such a presence
based off his body language alone and
and being with him and then something i
don't know like for as much as people
have complained about the mandalorian
even being like you know a slow-moving
show that's very contained in a lot of
ways i still feel like he brings with
him this presence
that just lights up the screen in an
interesting way even when he doesn't
have grog because that was the other
thing is you know people are thinking
and i'm sure you know part of it is
they've teased you know he's gonna go
see him at some point you know groggy
will figure back in probably but you
know two to have it be like no he's just
back alone it's still just as intriguing
to watch him there yeah um but i am it
does get me excited that maybe two maybe
we will all be on the same page next
week you know i mean given depending on
how he mixes in with the present of boba
fett's story maybe that will be the shot
in the arm some people who haven't been
enjoying the show as much will need you
know next week or something like that
uh yeah i mean that's that's what i'm
most interested in with mando being here
is seeing him blend into the world and
what he's like as a supporting character
for the boba fett series yeah because
right now i'm like i could just go for
bando season three yeah i know a lot of
love you just shifted gears and it was
just his show uh so that's that's the
one thing is i don't want it to undercut
that because it's still i i have been
enjoying the setup of of book of boba
fett uh quite a lot i'm like we're only
four episodes in guys uh that's what it
feels like now like we're only four
episodes in the boba
there's so much more to unpack and and
like mandalorian
um was you know fresh and exciting it
was the first star wars show live action
on this caliber
uh so there was a lot more you know like
love to behold and were coming off of
films that were being divisive for a lot
of fans
so
you know i i and it did take a while to
to propel people to the i really love
this show you know it was definitely
faster than what how people have been
with the book of [ __ ] but there's
been a lot of having to separate how
great mando is yeah and then adjust to
this new one and that's not to say some
of the filmmaking qualities or the
execution of the writing sure is not
the strongest in certain areas that it
can be i'm not saying those criticisms
are invalid uh i just think that
uh you know still needed some time to
really
give now that we were like we're done
with the flashbacks let's focus on the
present
the first episode of the president is a
pure mandalorian story which is cool
it's like you got the n1 starfighter
moment and i'm wondering it does make me
wonder
what the the what they've been doing
with mando and uh
because you do kind of pau there's been
like
theories forever about grogu and what
his connection is being a jedi lineage
and all that
uh he's with luke skywalker and
you know like like we pointed out he had
the thing
with a part of the engine of the pot
racing in one episode when he was
borrowing some things he used so we had
that
and then here he's getting an n1
starfighter which would make you pretty
it's on tattooing so you would assume
that's anakin's yeah
um
because yeah it's not like he was the
only one with that ship i mean he
injected in the phantom menace you know
but that like he that is the ship he
uses so
it does make me wonder if they're
building because they did so much like
nostalgia for the prequels in this
episode yes like they were the shots
were directly like remember the pod
racing yeah yeah yeah yeah going through
the narrow canyons yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i mean maybe i mean i i you
know that's something that marvel has
certainly been doing you know kind of
very focally lately is going back to the
things that not everybody loved and then
legitimizing them in new ways and so i
can absolutely see them mining further
from the prequels or for more of those
things to make them feel more legit and
more vital and more worthwhile in the
re-watching because that's also part of
this it's just you get a big canonical
you know revisitation cycle i don't
think the prequels ever had that issue
of feeling of importance
yeah
they they've always felt super important
and uh and like the level of revere that
dave filoni has for the actual
storytelling
like the way he speaks on it makes me go
[ __ ] maybe i was wrong about feminism
he's actually i think that's why the
prequels are are still so important for
star wars fans because
whatever you think of the actual
storytelling and filmmaking yeah
whatever story points at hand are still
worthwhile they're still very integral
to the world yeah still very entitled to
the world building whereas some people
kind of feel like with this disney
sequel that they're you
know
you can't really skip the prequel yeah
those prequels are if you want to get
the world and the lore like there's
they're vital
um
so
yeah i don't know maybe it just goes to
service enhancing the appreciation for
that or maybe they're just doing some
fun stuff like kelly motto getting some
of her back here i actually dated the
job was like it's the most time i feel
like we've actually just spent with her
in kind of a quirkier sense oh yeah like
they really allowed for a little bit
more of just let's let's spend a little
bit time with the comedy here of like
mando traveling having to put his
weapons in a sh on a briefcase and then
a lot of hanging out with kelly motto um
which was a lot of fun like amy sedaris
is always great he just dares right yeah
yeah she's always fantastic
she bangs jobless
disgusting and it's funny because as
much as this episode did have like a
sprawling or more expansive feel as
compared to the previous couple
this also did feel kind of like i like
that we spent our time mostly with
the armorer and
and then pelimoto and it's most of what
we're doing you know it's still pretty
contained that but yeah but the parts
that you're spending time with and that
are taking their time you know still
feel like they match the move the story
motion of something like the mandalorian
but also makes sense here well it's like
this episode was so important before
dinjarin yes this is such an important
episode for his journey it's literally
the setup of what i
i'm assuming is the setup for mandalore
in season three
like this is so so important for him
baby armor that now it's but they also
executed in such a weird way in terms of
where to place this yeah of
it it's like okay for the live-action
ahsoka show you should you should
probably watch the mandalorian episode
she's in yes right you don't have to
watch all of mandalorians season two but
you should probably watch the one
choosing the intro yes
um
and then to hear
that's what they've done with this
is
okay it seems like whatever he's dealing
with next like maybe he'll meet up with
grogu and we'll see that maybe that will
be just as important
but it sounds like that if you're
someone who's into mandalorian season
one and two but you don't really care to
watch book of boba fett that you'll have
to watch yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah this will be canonical because
there's too much important history yeah
i mean because rude is a mandalorian
yeah that's like part of his whole
identity which he has spent so long
grappling and they [ __ ] they actually
explained back backstory because a lot
of people watched the mandalorian didn't
watch clone wars or rebels and so you
you know they explained this stuff here
and they don't even explain i was like
all of them they they boil it down on
the greatest wikipedia description ever
so uh yeah like you it's it's so
important and it's it's i don't know
it's like as much as i really enjoyed
this episode i'm also fascinated with
the more of the feelings of what this
does if this is actually in service of
book of boba fett or it just makes you
go i don't really care about before this
was originally the season three opener
for mandalorian that then got
transplanted into boba fett for some
other reason for the greater grander
scope of the story i mean they would
have to have um there's no way it's like
they shot mando season three and they
placed it's just because of the
mechanics of the plot in the episode
um
it's also really convenient that he
would show up there when they're just
like we need to be muscled
yeah right around the time panic shows
back up he'd happen to
[Music]
and i'm assuming he was updated on boba
taking over i guess i mean yeah she just
must be there like we must cut away
right before she gives the big info dump
well i mean she he she says like boba
needs help yeah i mean he just he
assumes for boba yeah he assumes boba so
i'm assuming he knows that boba is now
in charge either that or he just assumes
that if i'm seeing fennec i left them
two together so it must be bobo related
or something like gotcha yeah i mean i
wouldn't be surprised if word made it
out there because it's not that far away
from where boba is so but then again to
get benefit of the doubt i'm also
wondering if the intention of like the
first four episodes have a very specific
tone and style
now we're really shifting gears and how
we're gonna proceed and if like boba and
mando are together and that's like i'm
assuming we'll probably get other
mandalorians as well
like okay is the tone really going to
take a shift now for the book of boba
fett the series yeah or is it going to
be the same
he's going to kill dinjar and take the
dark saber and re-establish
i'm a true mandalorian now yeah
i don't know i've really been enjoying
i've really been enjoying booger bow
with it a lot and uh
but yeah i guess my thing comes down to
is like just didn't feel at all like i
was watching the book of boba fett
anymore it was nice to watch the
mandalorian again yeah
that's what it was did you realize i
missed how much i missed the mandalorian
and also i guess i will say to boba
fett's credit that it doesn't just feel
like a different version of the same the
mandalorian like it definitely has its
own
separate tone and feel to the point
where when you do shift to following
dinger for a whole episode it feels like
it's totally on the show yeah that's why
i was saying that i thought it would be
danjarin
like what it would be like to see
dinjarn in the world of book of boba
fett next week i said holy [ __ ] amanda
laurie yep
which i love
i did love it i did love it i can't
complain yeah all right guys
well yeah
having it let's just just wait to see
how it goes man guys subscribe click
that bell hit that like button this was
awesome this was an awesome journey i've
really been enjoying this journey a lot
absolutely
um but yeah
hey
mom would do a
page
you got 30 seconds shot sar ben israel
hebrew name means storm
the gathering storm last week's boba
fett episode title that was about you
sarban israel because you have the power
within you you could be one of the most
pivotal influential people in all of the
galaxy and all you have to do is
complete your training and rise to your
mantle you are the true heir to all the
greatness and glory in the universe
serbian israel makes us happy that your
hero with this journey with us and hey
keep tight over there fulfill your
greatness and stay pledged we will
always have your back sarban israel love
you buddy happy 2022.
[Music]